- Tonight, when you go out in Vegas,
and you see a pretty girl at the bar,
you can't go up to her
and the opening move
is like here's my key, let's go fuck.
Yes, sir, what's your name?
- [Jeff] My name's Jeff, thanks for,
thanks for takin' my question.
- Sure, man.
- [Jeff] Kinda talkin'
about what would you do
for your mother and then for your brother
and then for a complete stranger?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Jeff] I started a company
called Red Monkey Foods.
We do gourmet seasonings and spices.
So since I am a complete stranger,
would you mind Tweetin' about
it to your 900,000 friends?
- See, what I find interesting is,
even though I just gave
a really passionate talk,
you went for the 19 year old dude move.
(applause)
- [Person In Audience] Woo!
- Good morning.
How are you guys?
(people in audience shout out)
Awesome.
Thank you, thank you
so much for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
Actually I have a funny intuition.
Let's start with this,
by a show of hands how many people here
have no idea who the fuck I am?
Raise your hand.
(audience laughs)
That's what I thought, hurts.
- [Male In Audience] So I've
seen a bunch of your stuff
on YouTube about
documenting versus creating?
just a minute ago, but it
always seemed like you connected
to personal pages or
each individual person
being a media person or
documenting their own person.
What about brands? Can brands document?
And what would that look like...
- Well, brands don't exist.
There's the people running the brand.
If here's Coca Cola, that's
some boring ass content.
It's the CEO of Coca Cola's interesting.
The sales kid in the market
of Coca Cola's interesting.
So I think of it like The
Office or SportsCenter anchors.
The people, like Office the sitcom, right?
Like, like the...
How many people here have
more than 10 employees?
Great. All these people have companies.
In those 10 employees, you
got some fuckin' characters
that we'd love to put some cameras on.
So to me, it's the
humans make up the brand.
The brand can't be content.
Your jean jacket is a
brand, but it can't talk.
So it's the humans behind the brand.
You could make it more about
the office environment,
less about the individual
person if you wanna go there
and you do that as a programmer right?
You give equal billing
on the 12 minute video
to the front desk person,
to the CEO, to the person
that cleans the carpets, to the customer.
How you storytell is up to you,
but absolutely that's
how people get into...
Brand always outpaces sales.
This is a room full of
people that understand sales.
I understand sales, but
the ultimate is brand
when it comes to you.
- Thanks, man.
- You got it, brother.
- [Russell] Hey Gary,
I'm Russell. How are you?
- Good, Russ.
- Awesome.
Quick shoutout to d-rock,
probably the best cameraman out there.
- Thank you.
- That's for Babin.
- Eat it, Babin.
- So I actually have my own company,
but I partnered with another
company to work with them
and coming from somebody you
give all your content out,
you give all your secrets
out, maybe you can kind of
elaborate on that as far as like...
- Like why do I give away
all my best advice for free?
- Why should people work together?
Because this is an industry
where it's kind of like
dog eat dog world so
why are you succeeding
and giving all your secrets
away at the same time?
- I mean, because doing the
right thing is the right thing.
Karma is practical.
(audience claps)
You know, I heard somebody rant earlier
that was like, "Hey,
when I win, I don't think
"it's coming outta you,"
the guy that closed.
I couldn't know who was on
stage, but I believe in that.
Because I love the idea
of 85 people here going
and listening to me, winning,
I didn't make anything for it,
but it then becomes brand.
If she goes out and listens
and then two years later
she's having dinner with
a friend and she's talkin'
about what happened to her life,
that friend might be the CEO of GE.
You know, I'm playing with the
biggest brands in the world.
I'm not trying to monetize my audience.
I'm trying to just bring
the most value in the world
and let that lift all
my other opportunities.
So I think giving away your best secrets
is the greatest strategy for two reasons:
Karma is practical and
leads to more business,
but here's the secret,
and it's even funnier,
99 percent of these
people are not gonna do
anything about it.
(audience applauds)
Somewhere about five or six years ago,
I realized this fact.
Holy shit, people aren't
gonna do anything with this.
So fuck it. There's still
gonna be plenty for me.
And I'm gonna be the most
lovable guy ever. I love this.
So, you know...
Giving away your best advice
is the business development
because the reason people work together
is 'cause it's nuanced, right?
I'm giving all the best advice,
but then, if I sat down...
What I'm about to do for that dude, right,
is we're gonna really look.
I know I'm theoretically right,
but I don't know the details
of what made his 20 thousand not work.
I gotta look.
And so there's always one extra step
when you look under the hood.
There's the theoretics
of how you fix a car.
I can tell you everything
about how to fix a car,
but until I look at your
car and look under the hood,
I'm like, "Oh, it was this part."
- [Joe] Gary Vee, Joe
Hyde with PRN Roofing
from Alabama.
- My friend.
- Two thing I wanna do.
I want everybody get out your cell phone
because we are trying to all build
our social media presence
here and wherever you are,
so people get out your
phones and follow Joe Hyde
on Instagram and like the
Facebook page for PRN Roofing.
My question is...
- Bro, hold on, hold on.
Did you really think that was a good idea?
(crowd laughs)
- We're here.
Gary, we're tryin' to blow up.
- No, bro, I honestly think
that was one of the worst moves
I've ever seen because...
(audience applauds)
And I'm not trying to
razz you. I appreciate...
I'm tryin' to give you love.
I love the passion to win.
The problem is you tried
to close on the first move.
You brought them no value
and you asked them to bring you value.
Like, you gave...
I will stand up here and
give a fuckload of value
and never mention one time
for any of them to follow me
and a lot more of them will follow me
than are gonna follow that
bullshit move that you just did.
(crowd applauds)
- I'm just tryin' to get known.
- I get it, but this was back
to the question that just happened.
This is why I want you to win.
That move is always gonna lose.
Tonight, when you go out in Vegas
and you see a pretty girl at the bar,
you can't go up to her and
the opening move is like,
"Here's my key. Let's go fuck."
(audience laughs)
But that's what you just did.
Let him hold it...
But that's what you just did
to this audience with business.
- My question, I was
gonna do this shout out.
My question to you is so,
you have a YouTube page,
everybody has a YouTube page,
maybe I should've done this
before I did that...
- Maybe.
- So our YouTube page, right?
Everybody's bringing content
and I know that you were
talkin' about podcasts.
- Yes.
- Is there an app or
some kind of technology
that we can transfer
maybe our YouTube content
into that content?
- Smart.
Whoever's doing your YouTube show
or the technical person can rip the audio
and then upload it to video.
And I did that for a long time,
but let me teach you this.
It was also not as effective
as when I changed my style.
I used to do the Ask Gary
Vee Show and I would rip it
and that would be my podcast.
Now I'm doing a lot of different things
that are a lot more podcast native
and my podcast has done better.
But, it is the absolute right first move,
it's a great, great thought,
and that's exactly what you should do.
You should strip the audio
out of the YouTube show
and post it as a podcast.
A hundred percent great start.
- [Joe] So there's no,
like, app or anything?
- There probably is. You're
gonna love this about me.
I don't like to talk
about shit I don't know.
There's a reason I got D's and F's.
It's 'cause I don't focus
on dumb shit, right?
You can literally go to Google right now
and type in 'How do I strip the audio
out of my YouTube video and
put on a podcast?', Enter.
(audience claps)
- Thank you, Gary.
- You got it, brother.
- [Man In Audience] Nobody else will be
allowed to embarrass me again.
- By the way, that didn't embarrass you.
First of all, I appreciate
the gangster nature of it.
I just want him to win.
I just know that move's
not gonna work, you know.
And that's all. He's not embarrassing.
I kind of fuckin' loved it.
Alright, let's do it.
- [Brian] Hey Gary, this
is Brian (muffled by echo).
I'm super stoked to be here.
Biggest hustler in the world.
We all have gotten to
see a legend right here.
So my question is, how can
we harness the hustle gene?
How can we pass on the hustle gene?
- You can't.
- To our companies.
And how can we instill this?
- You can't.
What you can do is you can hustle.
And then people will either ride up to it
or run away from it.
Like, I don't judge my people.
First of all, nobody that works for you
should hustle as hard as you.
Period.
You want somebody to hustle
as hard as you that works for you,
give them the same economics
you're taking home.
That's the truth.
(audience applauds)
Number two, with kids.
Rich kids aren't gonna care as much as you
about money because you didn't have any
and so you had to fight for
it and then that's just real.
So I think...
I set the tone for my
company. Some people rise up.
Some people find their work-life balance.
Some people bounce.
I'm not in the game of
thinking that's important.
If I feel good about what
I'm paying somebody for
for what I'm getting in return,
I don't need to judge that
they need to work harder.
I don't wanna get a deal from my people.
Do you understand?
I want my people to be on my team.
Not me getting more value out of them.
It's a huge mistake of business owners.
- [Joe] Joe Fredrick. Smart Roof.
Obviously, I speak for
everybody in this room
when I say I fuckin' love
listening to you talk.
- Thank you, brother.
(audience cheers)
- [Joe] So my question for you is this,
and it's something I
probably could've Googled,
but I don't want to sift
through a bunch of bullshit.
- Respect. I respect that.
- I value your opinion.
- Go ahead.
- If you would say the number one rule
or the top five rules
or the ten commandments
of creating and developing content
for social media ads, what would you do?
- Number one, you have to understand that
that gentleman right there, Scott,
when he's on Facebook
and he's on Instagram,
he's a different person.
He uses Facebook for one thing.
He uses LinkedIn for another thing.
He uses Twitter for another thing.
You have to understand
the psychology of a person
when they're consuming your content
'cause the context of that matters.
Number two, never put out
a piece of content ever
that is in your best interest
and not your audiences.
The number one reason
that 99 percent of you
are losing is because you put out content
that is completely predicated
on this piece of content
is gonna make me a sale.
Content is at an abundance.
People want content
that brings them value.
Educate, don't sell.
So I put out content that's valuable.
That's why people like it.
Then that leads to it. It's patience.
The lack of patience
with people's content.
Understand the context of where
you're putting out content.
Make the content about them.
You know, who's gonna win in three years
on Facebook in the storm business?
The person who make the video
that everybody in town sees
24 hours before the storm that says,
"Here's how you avoid
having me and my competition
"come to you have to fix your thing.
"Do this, do that, do this."
Then you're a resource for them.
Everybody in town's gonna see that,
and then when 90 percent of them don't,
80 percent of that 90 percent's
gonna reach out to you.
- [Joe] So to follow up on that,
what you would say is
don't try to be like,
"Hey, we'll come out and
give you a free inspection."
We'll say, "Hey, most
homeowners don't understand
"the claims process. This is
the claims process and how..."
- One hundred percent.
Everybody's giving free inspections...
We know what you're doing.
Your free is fuckin' loaded.
Nobody wants your fuckin'
loaded free, dick.
(audience laughs)
- Fuckin' love you, brother. Thank you.
- Love you. Makes me happy.
- [Male Audience Member]
So I was just wondering
if you could just say
something to my son, James.
He's 24.
- Come here.
- On video.
- That'd be awesome.
- Come here.
- This is for my son James.
- Here, let me do a face...
- Do you want me to call
him or just videotape it?
- Hey, James, it's Gary Vee.
I'm here with your dad.
I'm really fuckin' pissed
that you're not here.
(audience laughs)
But I respect that you're hustling.
That's exactly what you should be doing.
Hope we get to meet. See ya.
(audience applauds)
Thank you!
(hip hop beat)